as you know, the eu is
a central
investment policy in terms of coalition policy in the european
union
specifically it is about the framework conditions
for us a third of the eu budget we
have also made very good progress in the
negotiations and have set ourselves three
focal points for our
work that is to  less
bureaucracy, secondly, more
subsidiarity, ie
design options for the
member states, and thirdly,
more efficient controls after
today's discussion, we will use the
results to continue working on the chapters on
programming conditionality and
framework conditions as well as on
administration and control
way forward in what in the future